[Musique]
deux choses la première certaines
personnes parmi nous ce matin sont
programmés pour échouer il se pourrait
qu'ils soient programmés pour échouer
la deuxième c'est qu'une minorité une
toute petite minorité je pèse mes mots
est programmé pour réussir je vais vous
raconter une histoire un petit chapitre
de ma vie je les titres et quand je
serai grand
quand j'étais tout jeune je rêvais de
devenir pilote d'avion
je voulais découvrir le monde à travers
les nuages mais mon niveau plus ou moins
très fort en mathématiques m'a prouvé
tout de suite que ce n'était pas destiné
pour cette carrière après j'ai voulu
devenir pâtissier les gâteaux les
fondants au chocolat les crêpes
je me rappelle encore de la réaction de
mon père quand je lui ai dit papa je
veux devenir pâtissier me dit ceci
brunel farce et de la gourmandise
ce n'est pas grave quelques années plus
tard j'ai découvert le métier de
banquier à la télé et costumes des deux
voitures
les chiffres j'ai dit pourquoi pas et si
je devenais banquier je partis voir mon
père papa je crois que je vais dans une
banque et ils nous regardaient dit
brunel tu aimes trop l'argent alors là
ça commençait à devenir compliqué
jusqu'au jour où je crois j'étais en
troisième quand j'ai découvert le métier
d'artiste l'occurrence mettait deux
rappeurs way
j'enchaînais les chaînes cnn et steyn
c'était des gens
le rap c'est mon oxygène vecteur de me
wade mais paie vous ai compris que je
sois devenu star effectivement c'était
devenu la star du rap de mon collège je
danse sociale et ceci mon père était
enseignant dans le collège
quand il a appris mon actualité en tant
que star il m'a appelé dans sa chambre
et sans franchement ça m'arrivait il dit
ceci fiston honnêtement dans notre
famille est ce que tu as jamais
rencontré de griots j'ai compris le
message
ça devenait compliqué donc arriver en
terminale j'ai décidé qu'après mon bac
j'allais devenir diplomate
parce que pour moi il était temps de
quitter ce pays les deux temps pour moi
de découvrir le monde
donc j'ai donc fait des études en
diplomatie relations internationales et
après l'obtention de mon diplôme de
premier cycle
j'ai compris qu'il fallait partir à
l'étranger pour faire une spécialité
mais bon pas les moyens j'ai dû
abandonner son projet
alors partie de ce moment ça commençait
à devenir compliqué que vais-je faire
finalement quand je serai grand c'est
donc décidé comme plusieurs jeunes à
mona d'arrêter mes études et de me
lancer dans la vie active j'ai roulé ma
bosse un peu partout
premier aspect riences j'étais dans le
marketing à distance en résumé mes
journées c'était à l'aube au jour
service clientèle que plus pour vous
c'était pas pour moi quelques temps plus
tard j'ai démissionné
par la force des choses je me suis
retrouvé à l'aéroport international de
cotonou en tant qu'agent de sûreté
galons cravate
donc c'était jean rouge monsieurr
passeport votre vie d'avion je
contrôlais les visas entre deux ans
c'était pas moi j'étais pas à l'aise
avec ça je me sentais pas vivant j'ai
continué à chercher et par la force des
choses encore je me suis retrouvé à la
banque
ah oui j'ai concrétisé ce rêve
bref je les côtoie quelques mois j'étais
devenu banquier en griffe la base était
mademoiselle s'il vous plaît vous devez
acquitter votre chèque marché
machination bref tout ça commençait
vraiment nui ve
j'ai décidé de prendre ma vie en main et
c'est là je suis tombé dans un secteur
du jeu tous très passionnant la
communication est donc depuis trois ans
je suis publicitaires dans une agence de
communication réputé un métier où on
apprend pour faire simple à vendre du
rêve à vendre des émotions à vendre
certaines sensibilités au public
j'ai eu de la chance parce que j'ai des
promotionnaires jusqu'à présent ils
savent pas encore ce qu'ils vont faire
de leur vie et comme vous avez remarqué
dix ans après mon bac c'est à ce moment
là que je commence à savoir ce que je
vais faire de ma vie
c'est inadmissible chaque année nous
formons des jeunes africains nous
donnons de gros diplôme
nous les mettons sur le marché mais ce
que vous savez que ces derniers sont mal
formés
est ce que vous savez que ces derniers
sont mal orientés mais ce que vous savez
encore qu'ils sont sans repères
véritable franchement c'est un gros
problème
et moi je me pose la question suivante
on dit oui
la jeunesse la relève mais à cette
allure cette jeunesse là et c'est vrai à
quoi j'ai mes pistes 1
nous allons gonfler le taux de chômage
deux nous allons embaucher le taux
d'immigration en occident et 3 nous
allons définitivement à pauvres et notre
continent mais je pense avoir une idée
une idée qui pourrait révolutionner
notre système éducatif est ch'ti dans un
premier temps avant de permettre aux
élèves d'aller au baccalauréat
nous apprenions d'abord à mieux les
connaître franchement est ce que nous
connaissons vraiment nos élèves est ce
que nous connaissons vraiment nos
étudiants deuxième chose et si au lieu
de décourager les jeunes surtout en
afrique quand ils ont envie de faire un
certaine expérience en te décourage et
si on apprenait à développer leur
potentiel et enfin et si on leur
présentait des africains qui ont réussi
en afrique
la magie des haies cette idée c'est tout
simple elle est toute simple un
programme de développement personnel
africain jeudi vient un programme de
développement personnel africain axée
sur la connaissance de soi et la
confiance en soi parce que pour moi
réussir c'est d'abord dans le mental
l'afrique en a besoin
la jeunesse africaine encore plus je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]